effort to save a firefighter's life  extends across the country we first  introduced you to brian kevin last night  the retired fdny firefighter is fighting  cancer brought about by his service in  new york on september 11th kevin has  friends and family here in vegas and  today they hosted a bone marrow drive in  search of a match for a transplant  he's currently in the chemotherapy  that's  to  sustain him while we're trying to find a  match he's gone through three or four  different processes he's gone into  remission and  and then  went the cancer came back so we're  hoping that the bone marrow transplant  will  settle it once and for all  bone marrow drives are also underway at  fire houses in new york city family and  friends say the drive today in vegas  helps cast a wider net to hopefully find  that match